from a law order SVU star's collapsed
lung to a British stuntman's paralysis
from the waist down these are some of
the small screen's ugliest onset
injuries
good wife is a courtroom drama that
debuted in 2009 the show's creators
Michelle and Robert King were inspired
after seeing many cases of wives
standing by their disgraced politician
husbands after they confessed to an
affair surprisingly a courtroom drama
made the cut for a list like this
nevertheless stunts aren't the only
thing that could go wrong on a
television set Kristen Chenoweth was on
the set of The Good Wife for an outdoor
sequence when a piece of lighting
production equipment fell on her head
during an appearance on Andy Cohen's
Watch What Happens Live the actress said
the terrifying event practically killed
her Chenoweth also revealed in the
interview that she felt unconscious
instantly and woke up in a hospital bed
the horrific accident left her with a
7-inch skull fracture and broken teeth
among other injuries the actor's doctor
told her that if it hadn't been for her
hair extensions she would have died that
day since they held the hairline
fracture on her head together she told
Cohen that she has long-standing
injuries as a result of the event and
regrets not suing CBS over it she
explained I didn't do it out of fear and
anxiety Netflix had its work cut out for
it when adapting Cowboy Bebop one of the
best anime shows of all time the Beloved
Sci-Fi series has a dedicated cult
following so getting the right cast was
always going to be vital John Cho was
ultimately cast as protagonist Spike
Spiegel however Cho heard his knee
during the filming of the highly
anticipated show tearing his ACL the ACL
tissue is the muscle that links the
thigh bone to the shin and is commonly
torn in athletes chose recuperation from
his ACL injury took a toll on him not
only physically but also mentally in a
promotional interview for the series the
actor told vulture that he was concerned
about his extended time off primarily
for how it affected the show's
production he told vulture I felt very
guilty that I had let the production
down and my cast and the crew in New
Zealand that had had a job and then they
didn't the next day
it's always a daunting task for
television Executives to develop a
police procedural that stands out from
the crowd the method 911 adopted was
depending on the sheer star power of
actors like Angela Bassett and Peter
Krause while bringing in talented guest
stars to support them UFC and WWE star
Ronda Rousey was one such guest however
Rousey's guest appearance did not go as
planned as she sustained a gruesome
injury while filming Rousey described
the event in a social media post
revealing that on the very first take on
a specific day her finger was crushed by
a boat door and nearly severed yeah I
looked down and my finger was barely
hanging on while showing a picture of
the injury Rousey wrote in the caption
of an Instagram post I thought I'd just
jammed my fingers so I finished the take
before looking after a break in the
action I told our director the situation
and was rushed via ambulance to the
hospital where they promptly reattached
my bone and tendon with a plate and
screws Rousey went on to praise the
medical team that worked on her finger
revealing that 50 of normal motion had
returned within three days of her
surgery
Prison Break debuted in 2005 and quickly
became a cultural phenomenon the drama
morphed into a sort of travel show with
the main characters being pulled into an
ever-growing government conspiracy that
forces them into different prisons all
over the world in season 5 a conspiracy
leads the gang to Yemen during the
shooting of an action scene an iron bar
fell from 20 feet and struck Dominic
Purcell on the head leaving him
seriously injured he told deadline I
dropped to my knees and I was in shock
I'm just leaning over and the blood is
just pouring out like a shower and my
stunt guy came up beside me and he said
your head split right open I can see
your skull your nose is on the other
side of your face because they were
shooting in a remote part of Morocco the
kind of medical assistance he needed
wasn't immediately available when the
doctors at the local Clinic he was taken
to started arguing amongst themselves he
walked out as Purcell explained to
deadline his girlfriend then took
control of the situation he told the
outlet she poured alcohol on my head and
wrapped me up in gauze and then Fox got
a helicopter and they flew me out of
Wars as a de Casablanca he was taken to
a renowned plastic surgeon in casablanc
who was able to fix him up the actor was
lucky to escape the ordeal with his life
but he still has visible scars on his
scalp to this day
um it was uh that's where the the wife
of my skull was showing Mariska Hargitay
has starred as Olivia Benson in over 500
episodes of Law and Order Special
Victims Unit not every episode has been
enjoyed a film for Harga day but one led
to a very serious injury she recalled
during an interview with Redbook I was
doing a stunt chasing a bad guy I jumped
and landed on pads but on the second
take something happened I just landed
wrong I got up and felt that something
inside was not quite right the actor
Shrugged it off as a muscle injury and
she seemed to get better however three
months later she was walking on the
beach when she suddenly experienced an
intense stabbing pain in her chest and
was unable to catch her breath the
actress revealed to Red Book they took
an x-ray and found that my right lung
was 50 collapsed I began to panic I was
so scared I had a procedure hoping to
Stave off more serious surgery but it
didn't work and I ended up in surgery
about two weeks later hargety was told
that the repaired lung was now healthier
than her other lung but that there was
still about a one in one thousand chance
that it would collapse again despite
those seemingly favorable odds however
her lung collapsed once again however
she isn't bitter about it the actress
told Redbook I get to be the one in 1000
in so many positive ways it balances out
I have so many blessings and I've
learned from all of my experiences and
my losses
as Stephen amell's tenure on Arrow ended
fans hoped that his next project would
capitalize on his abilities as a
physical actor with considerable
dramatic chops when the trailer for
heels was released it promised to do
just that in an inventive Way the show
was about a wrestler in a small town
attempting to build a wrestling Dynasty
the nature of the show meant that Amel
would have to do a lot of physical stuff
thus putting himself in potential danger
it wasn't long before he picked up a
nasty injury Amel told ABC I overshot it
Coast to Coast on our first day of
filling wrestling stuff and suffered a
compression fracture I'm very fortunate
and lucky that it was an injury that
sounds scary but didn't require surgery
it just sort of healed on its own it was
a terrifying moment not just for him but
for everyone involved in the production
the actor told ABC I certainly scared a
lot of people Amel developed a huge
respect for professional wrestlers while
making the show he went on to say that
he has no intention of swapping his
comfortable life as an actor for the
grind of the pro wrestling circuit
anytime soon
jackass was once the most contentious
show on television the show's concept
stems back to the 1990s when Johnny
Knoxville was trying to break into
Hollywood he couldn't find acting work
so he turned to journalism while
attending a career in journalism
Knoxville intended to put together an
article about himself testing
self-defense equipment when Jeff
Tremaine the editor of a Skateboard
Magazine heard about the idea he asked
if he could film it Knoxville was
introduced to a bunch of like-minded
skaters and jackass was born the MTV
show went on to be a massive success but
with a concept like that serious
injuries are inevitable Knoxville told
Entertainment Weekly I have so many
doctors in my phone I have to go for a
tune-up with one doctor or another at
least once a month now the actor and
stuntman sustained so many injuries
during his jackass days that it's a
wonder he's still walking from herniated
discs and torn tendons to Serious
concussions Knoxville has been through
it all my left eye popped out of its
socket and it was the more I blew the
farther it was coming and so that
freaked me out in his Entertainment
Weekly interview Knoxville admitted
sometimes after concussion you get a
little down but it kind of works itself
out I feel like I'm very strong
physically and mentally I'm very lucky
it doesn't always work out like this for
a man who's had the amount of injuries
that I've had
Ozzy Osbourne first gained notoriety in
the 1970s as the lead singer of the
British rock band Black Sabbath
Osborne's Fame went beyond the band as
his Antics made him notorious in the
tabloids in the early 2000s MTV
capitalized on Osborne celebrity by
green lighting a reality show about him
and his family the osbornes didn't shy
away from revealing Big Life events such
as Sharon's cancer battle one such
significant event was the quad bike
accident that injured Ozzy Osborne was
riding his quad bike on the grounds of
the family's Estate in England when he
hit some uneven ground and was thrown
from the vehicle Osborne's bodyguard Sam
Ruston told ABC as the bike's tumbling
and he's tumbling he actually somehow
gets entangled in the bike and he's
rolling with the bike I turned him over
and I put my head on his chest and I
hear no breath no heartbeat nothing
Rustin performed mouth-to-mouth on
Osborne when The Rocker finally came
around he was immediately transported to
a hospital doctors found that one of
Osborne's lungs was partially collapsed
and several bones were damaged eight of
Osborne's ribs some of his vertebrae and
his left collarbone were all fractured
in 2019 he revealed that he was still
feeling the after effects of the
accident in an interview with SiriusXM
Osborne revealed for the last 10 years
I've been getting electric shocks down
my arm
at this point in history Simon Cowell
standing in pop culture is more related
to his reputation as a caustic judge on
numerous Talent programs than to his
actual day job as a record label head
however few fans are aware that Cowell
himself was once a contestant on an
obscure talent show called sale of the
century his fondness for the format
along with his notion that controversy
Garner's attention inspired Kell to
create the Got Talent franchise since
then the Got Talent franchise has
spawned over a hundred spin-offs
America's Got Talent extreme was one
such spin-off the concept was the same
as in previous incarnations with a
combination of the judges hosts and
viewers voting for their favorite
contestant the only difference was that
this version contained Daredevil stunts
however a horrific accident on the set
resulted in the show being suspended
indefinitely in 2021 with Cowell pulling
the plug soon after Jonathan Goodwin an
experienced British stunt performer had
been in several UK television shows
before competing on America's Got Talent
extreme he was crushed between two
automobiles after his stunt on America's
Got Talent extreme went tragically wrong
as a result Goodwin was paralyzed from
the waist down the prognosis is that
that you know unless there's some sort
of amazing thing that happens that this
is me from from here on out but Goodwin
is doing his best to maintain a positive
attitude during an appearance on loose
women he had this to say I wouldn't wish
it on anybody but I think that with all
the physical challenges I've had in my
life I'm uniquely adapted to dealing
with it
[Music]